I had a call with you yesterday, and I heard you tell me I should look into chemo to get my
mass shrinkage started. Please confirm you think that might help me. Or should we give the right
for chance for a week by lymphoma mass is large. Yes, so the answer to that is always going to be
have to be your call. I can't legally tell a person not to go do a biopsy or to go do a biopsy.
I'm just going to give you my opinion. If there's going to be a process that has you have to go
through, you have to have it at a biopsy yet, you're not going to just be able to go in and say,
okay, I need to get started with chemo. Let's get started right away. It's going to be a process of
we have to schedule the biopsy. Then we have to schedule the chemo. It could be two weeks down the
road before anything gets started. There can be a benefit to getting the biopsy now. At least
getting it scheduled. We get it probably won't get scheduled until next week. Then once those
results come back, which might be several days, then you could schedule the chemo. But you did
it will give us some time. In that, we'll be a week down the road before chemo would even be an
option. Getting started with getting a biopsy may be in order if your mass is large. The concern
with having a large abdominal mass of any kind is that it could put pressure on other organs.
If it blocks your intestinal tract, then we're in trouble. You have an intestinal blockage.
You can't just live with an intestinal blockage. If it puts pressure on the pancreas and causes
pancreatitis, that is a huge crisis. Pancreatitis inflammation of the pancreas can cause an infection
in the pancreas. You don't want to find yourself in a position of an emergency. If you're going to the
ER in an emergency situation and they're having to do an emergency surgery, if you can possibly
plan ahead and get in some things done, that would have to take place if you want to do the chemo.
That would be, in this case, getting a biopsy may be wise to get that scheduled so that if
doing the rife doesn't make a big difference within the first couple of weeks and things are going
the wrong direction, you have the ability to go in and do chemo. Without the biopsy,
you don't have the ability to get started with chemo until you jump through that hoop. So if you could
jump through that hoop so you're more prepared, should you want to do chemo that might be a good idea.
That's all I'm saying. It doesn't mean you have to go in scheduled chemo right away,
but at least you'd be prepared so that you're not in an emergency situation.